- But I hear you actually DJ on sets.
Is this true?
- Well, I mean.
- Are you like a wicky-wicky, yeah.
- I mean, no, see, see, that's the thing.
I wish I could wicky-wicky,
but I don't wicky-wicky.
I have-
- Oh, you're like, I pull up my playlist.
- Exactly.
- Yeah, okay, yeah.
- And I bring these really
fun big Bluetooth speakers,
and I just play tunes for
the cast and the crew.
And I just love like
anything with a boogie.
Anything with a boogie, baby, you know.
Anything with a boogie.
- All right, all right.
Do you ever get Kurt to sing along to his?
'Cause he was there 50% of the time.
- No, no, no, yes.
So he was, he's a very chill, laid back,
cool, cool customer.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- But he, there's certain music
that I could get him really into.
And ironically, and, you know,
I've done Broadway a couple of times
and I'm very, very proud
of the Broadway I've done.
I had no idea that Kurt
was a huge Broadway fan.
- [Kelly] Wait, what?
- (mimicking explosion) Blew my mind.
And his favorite show is "Aida,"
and he's seen it like a dozen times.
- [Kelly] What?
- He's seen it like a dozen times.
And so very surreptitiously,
that's the word,
I started playing "Aida," and
I put it next to his chair,
and then I could see and
I'm just kinda watching him,
and he starts just singing
to it a little bit.
I was like, "Ha ha!
"I got you."
- I got you.
That's awesome.
I would've never guessed
that, that's awesome.
- [Zachary] Yeah, never
in a million years, yeah.
- He's very well-rounded, isn't he?
- Yeah, I think so.
- A grand fellow.
- Yeah, he's a 360 human being.
- [Kelly] Yes, yes.